so
[Music]
the religion of art belongs to the
ethical spirit which we earlier saw
perish in the condition of right or law
that is in the proposition
the self is such the abstract person is
absolute being
in the ethical life the self is
submerged in the spirit of its people it
is the universality that is filled
but simple individuality raises itself
out of this content and its levity
refines it into a person into the
abstract universality of right or law
in this the reality of the ethical
spirit is lost and having lost all
content the spirits of national
individuals are gathered into a single
pantheon not into a pantheon of picture
thought whose powerless form lets each
spirit go its own way but into the
pantheon of abstract universality of
pure thought which disembodies them and
imparts to the spiritless self to the
individual person a being that is in and
for itself
in paragraph 750 much like the two
preceding it and like those that are yet
to come we see that hegel is not yet
telling us what he means by
revealed religion
instead he is contrasting whatever he's
going to be talking about which i think
is implicitly being revealed here
to
the previous
form of religion religion in the form of
art
religion right
and to
dynamics that have taken place and here
is a good point for us to remind
ourselves of something that he told us
very early on in the religions section
namely
that the previous dialectical
developments found in the earlier
sections
consciousness self-consciousness reason
and spirit
are being brought together
as like
threads going into a knot and so there's
going to be some replaying
of what took place before but as always
with hegel the replay is always a remix
you could say there's never uh simply
repetition
instead it's sublation you know and so
the essential aspects are being
hearkened back to and that that's going
to happen here in this paragraph and
even more so in the two paragraphs to
come
so he tells us that the religion of art
belongs to the ethical spirit right and
this is something that we saw back at
the very beginning of the
spirit section the longest portion of
the work and he says we saw it earlier
perish
we saw it go under
in what the condition of right
or law
so
law or right is wrecked um and and
miller here is being a little pleonastic
he could have just said in the condition
of right or justice or law
this is a very broad term
and so what we see is the zitica
uh you know
geist is going to
lose what is really essential to it as
ethical as it like
zitten is customer morris you know we
get the word ethics from ethos
uh moral from maurice and this is very
important for
um thinking about moral theory and
practice prior to the modern age right
that conception of it and that's what
gets lost
in the transition to something much more
comprehensive something
that is universal something that is
abstract and you might even say
in many respects thinking about it
historically more
right
more
ethical in a different sense right
so
hegel tells us that
now we have a different proposition
earlier the proposition and i've kind of
signaled this by the way i've written it
before earlier the proposition in the
last two paragraphs has been the self
is absolute being but now we're
understanding what the self is and if we
think back to the previous paragraph
where the
self rather than substance or subject
rather than substance has become the
subject right
then
we have to say well what is the essence
of that and here it is being portrayed
as the self as such al zolka right as
the abstract person what does it mean to
be an abstract person
you and i are
concrete persons we are people who have
determinancy
and you know part of that is for example
gender or
age or you know i'm tall as opposed to
being short i have long hair perhaps you
have no hair or short hair some of these
things are very easy to change i can get
a clippers and turn my long hair into no
hair right
i can't change my eye color unless i you
know use contacts or get some weird dye
to put into my eyes or things like that
but all of those things are things about
me
as such and you have all of those to be
treated as an abstract person to be
made you know into absolute being as an
abstract person
is to be within we might say
a system
um and you know if you think back to how
things worked before
at the top was the lord of the world and
everybody else is basically equal
underneath that lord
and
you know we could also think about death
in in that respect the absolute master
back in the master slave dialectic
abstract personhood is not
the same thing as real or concrete or
actual personhood but it is something
that matters it is something that
defines us
when you make an appeal to your
human rights you are not appealing to
yourself as a concrete person
as a matter of fact your rights are
probably being transgressed precisely
who based on who you are is a concrete
person they're like well because you're
this ethnicity we can trample on your
rights because you're this gender we
don't have to respect your rights and
then you insist i am a person like all
the rest of these
that's an
abstraction abstractions have real
meaning and value now he goes on and he
says in the ethical life
the self is submerged in the spirit of
its people so in this previous form
ethical life
right we have the spirit of the people
the geist of fook right and then the
self is just part of that the people is
the universal the self is the mere
particular
or individual
who doesn't you know matter except in so
far as they fit into
that particular
system that particular framework
and he says that the self
uh is submerged in this spirit of the
people the it is the universality that
is filled right
but simple individuality
raises itself
out of this content he says simple
individuality
emerges as we've seen it do in the
religion of art but also in the spirit
section and it doesn't do so
boom automatically right in one fell
swoop it takes a whole bunch of
cumulative steps and sometimes missteps
and retracing its path this doesn't
happen to everybody all at once
but it does happen to some and he talks
about its levity this is a term that
we've brought up several times we we
should talk about
you know like right making when we say
making light of something it's got a
cognitive relationship to this
levity the spirit of levity here
or the
attitude of levity is one of not taking
things as seriously as they want to be
taken and that is what hegel thinks
is happening
here
in in the previous developments
particularly with comedy which again is
not just a genre it's you might say a
mode of existing
and he says the levity refines it into a
person
what is a person into the abstract
universality of right or law and here i
want to pause for a minute and spell
something out that hegel's not spelling
out here
the abstract universality and there's
two abstract universalities that are
going to play a role here in this
there's going to be a parallelism taking
place the abstract universality of law
or right doesn't exist in a person
as such it's not like the single person
robinson caruso style you know
extricated themselves from society
in a shipwreck or whatever and then
suddenly discovers law right you only
have law or right
in relation to other consciousnesses
so there is a relation to the other here
there is a
system here within which the person can
be
a simple individuality can be
the
abstract person who is absolute being
right
and so he tells us now here's the other
side of the parallelism in this the
reality
of ethical spirit is lost interestingly
he doesn't use the term vehicle kite
here he uses the term reality
which we translate by its cognate
reality
and the you know being real being you
know being what it is presenting itself
to us that gets lost in this it's not
just actuality or being there that is
lost it is you could say it's purpose
it's meaning
and so he says the reality of the
ethical spirit is lost
having lost all content why did it lose
all content well because the content
fled
into simple individualities
right who are still working within the
framework of a society
but are probably not buying into it
they're exploiting it they're treating
it not as something sacred
but is something to be
used and he says
the spirits of national individuals are
gathered into a single
pantheon so national individuals
are folk individual individual
individualites right
we saw these referenced
previously
in the religion as a work of art section
and the notion of pantheon a pantheon
is a
entirety upon right the whole
of the divine beings and so it's a way
of making sense out of divinity
and here the pantheon
he says is not a pantheon of picture
thought of you know forced elong
whose powerless form lets each spirit go
its way
so it's not you know well let zeus do
what zeus does and apollo does apollo's
thing and hestia does hestia's thing but
they're all one big happy family
no he says the pantheon of abstract
universality
pure thought
pure thought not the thought of the gods
the thought of humans
which disembodies them and imparts to
the spiritless self
to the individual person
a being that is in and for itself so the
pantheon itself is transformed what we
should imagine of course here is that
lurking behind the scenes sooner or
later will be the lord of the world who
we saw invoke before but that's not
being explicitly discussed here
but this self has through its emptiness
let the content go free it is only
within itself that consciousness is
essence its own existence the legal
recognition of the person is the
unfilled abstraction what it possesses
therefore
is rather only the thought of itself or
in other words in the mode in which it
immediately exists and knows itself as
object it is something that is not
hence it is only the stoic independence
of thought which passes through the
dialectic of the skeptical consciousness
to find its truth in that shape which we
have called the unhappy
self-consciousness
paragraph 751 continues this backwards
looking thematic that i just referenced
in earlier paragraphs and here now we
get to see
going all the way back to the
self-consciousness section some explicit
references to
the dynamic that happens after the
famous master slave dialectic and which
is much more important than what's going
on in that short dynamic namely the
transition to stoicism as a mode of
dealing with self-consciousness and its
lack of recognition and the problematic
of the world that it lives in the
transition then to
skepticism and then finally the much
longer section of the unhappy
consciousness which is going to provide
us
with you might say the
not necessarily
thematic but certainly the the tone the
original
uh tincture the the coloring of how god
is being approached in revealed religion
at least for part of it so we we have
plenty of time to talk about what
happened in the unhappy consciousness
section we don't have to go into that in
great detail so he's talking about the
self the self that is now
released from freed from
the confines of ethical life and the
ethical spirit and in this case also
the
religion in the form of art which was
connected with the eth you know the
ethos of a people
and he says this self
has through its emptiness leer height
right so the self itself is empty let
the content go free
and now this is very interesting isn't
it
because what content are we talking
about i i mentioned the difference
between
our concrete
real uh what hegel called virklica
selves who who you and i are in the last
paragraph and an abstract
personhood
which is
articulated and regulated and respected
by some sort of system
of laws and rules and also perhaps by a
being who gives those
now we actually have two different kinds
of non-concrete
ways of of being for the self
and
these are contrasted against each other
what's been left out is the concrete
person
so he says the content has gone free it
is only within itself and that's just
right
you could say in itself within itself
that consciousness
is essence these
um consciousness
is what matters right and here we have a
rather we have an abstract way of being
but it's not the abstraction
of that within the legal
system
this is you could say that of
metaphysics or philosophy or perhaps
even morality in you know uh a sense
that is connected with metaphysics and
he says that
by contrast to this
its own existence
eigen is dozen so we've got a
distinction here between
essence and what it is in itself and
then it's reality it's it's being there
within something and this uh he's got a
very interesting term here it's legal
recognition of the person
notice the middle term in that
honor con sein
honor kennen is something that
self-consciousness
has been seeking throughout the entirety
of the phenomenology once it became
thematized early on
in the self-consciousness section you
only truly exist
as a self-consciousness in relation to
other self-consciousness
which wants you to recognize it or
acknowledge it and
which you want recognition or
acknowledgement from there's all sorts
of impasses concerning this we've seen
this come up over and over and over
again
notice the language here
it's not honor kennen
on air can't sein
it's already been recognized on akant it
it's that's past
zein the being that way so the honor
consign the person the person uh the the
recognition being having been recognized
belongs to the person you could say
rec league
legal uh justice oriented um
social however we want to
frame this
its own existence the legal recognition
of the person then he says is the
unfilled unrefilled
abstraction
but these are actually both abstractions
aren't they from the person or the
individual who
who is the concrete individual we were
using the term person over here on the
other side so perhaps we want to avoid
confusing them and he says what it
possesses so what this side what the
self possesses is rather only the
thought
of itself notice what he doesn't say
there it's the thought of itself not its
feelings not its
social relations not its choices it's
volitions even the way it talks about
itself it's thought of itself that is
why it's also abstract he says or in
other modes in other words in the mode
in which it immediately
exists and knows itself as object
gergenstand it conceptualizes
itself it is something that is
not actual nicked vehicles so the the
vehicle
zelps the the you know actual self is
neither here on the side of essence nor
here on the side of legal recognition of
the person in its own existence within
the system it's been lost as content in
some way
now here's where hegel makes a
interesting correlation
so he says
hence
it is only the stoic independence of
thought
stendy kite a term we saw a little bit
earlier coming up right independence of
thought
associated with what hegel made of
stoicism
way back in the self-consciousness
section
stoicism emerges here not as the actual
philosophy of stoicism
but as standing in for something it's
already sort of a distortion of what
historically stoicism was
but this is typical hegel the idea
is something that we can find cropping
up again but notice that stoic
thought
independence of thought focused on oh i
am whatever else is happening in the
world out here i am at least within my
inner citadel of my thinking
and i can you know have control over
that
we saw
that was not stable that was not
sustainable and now miller
introduces the word dialectic here hegel
doesn't actually say that in the text he
says begun
if you want to read it as a dialectical
movement well of course it is because
this whole thing is dialectic
i'm just kind of a stickler sometimes
for being a little bit more literal he
says it passes through the dialectic of
the skeptical consciousness okay that's
true it goes through the movement of
skeptical consciousness skepticism you
remember even turns on itself it
introduces a kind of
madness urtum right and then it lands in
the much longer
movement of the unhappy consciousness
where he says uh it finds its truth in
that shape you know in that gestalt
it finds its truth it's var height what
finds its truth independence of thought
which we have called the unhappy
self-consciousness where there isn't
actually independence of thought except
in a
trivial way what has actually has
independence is the eternal the
unchanging the divine projected outside
of oneself and so hegel is saying that
this is
you know a process that we've traversed
before and we're going through something
similar to it now as we transition into
revealed religion
this self-consciousness knows what the
validity of the abstract person amounts
to in reality and equally in pure
thought it knows that such validity is
rather a complete loss it is itself this
conscious loss of itself and the
alienation of its knowledge about itself
we see that this unhappy consciousness
constitutes the counterpart and the
completion of the cosmic consciousness
that is perfectly happy within itself
into the latter all divine being returns
or it is the complete alienation of
substance
the unhappy consciousness on the other
hand is conversely the tragic fate of
the certainty of self that aims to be
absolute it is the consciousness of the
loss of all essential being in this
certainty of itself and of the loss even
of this knowledge about itself the loss
of substance as well as of the self it
is the grief which expresses itself in
the hard saying that
god is dead
paragraph
752 starts to bring things to a
close but open us up to other
developments and it ends with that
lapidary
formula so often associated with
nietzsche but which we see is here in
hegel who calls it a hard saying a heart
of war right god is dead and we'll talk
about the significance of that a bit
more
in a bit but let's look at where we're
beginning
he's ended the previous paragraph by
invoking the unhappy self-consciousness
and then he tells us that
this self-consciousness namely the
unhappy self-consciousness
knows what the validity of the abstract
person amounts to in reality
and equally in pure thought
now this is interesting because
was this talked about a lot in that that
section well
no and so this is something a bit new
bringing things together
he says it knows such validity
is a complete loss
it is itself this conscious loss of
itself
and the alienation of its knowledge
about itself
so we see here that what we're dealing
with
is no longer the unhappy consciousness
but the unhappy
self-consciousness
which is a form
of consciousness but which is a
development past
the unhappy consciousness of the
self-consciousness
section and there's you know more going
on here well we're in the religion
section so the previous forms as we've
talked about before the previous paths
that spirit has taken
are now being brought to a more
developed level and this is going to
pave the way
for
something
new something
that advances
the dialectic
and here he makes a contrast
he says
we see this now he says unhappy
consciousness
no longer just unhappy
self-consciousness
constitutes
the counterpart and completion of the
cosmic consciousness so there's a lot
going on here that we should unpack a
little bit we've got the unhappy
consciousness
what is what does higgle mean by this
cosmic cosmicia
consciousness it doesn't define it
instead we have to like think back well
where have we encountered something that
would be cosmic and here you want to put
aside any sort of new agey
or you know 19th 20th century
um
let's call it weak
superficial thought that uses the word
cosmic and think about what cosmos and
cosmicia would actually mean
so
if we go back to it it does in fact mean
you know the cosmos that we can observe
as well as
whatever is supposed to lie behind it
you know the
realm of the gods the
movements of the spheres and the fixed
stars right and the planets and stuff
like that that would all be cosmic and
it would affect us down here if we
still buy into that sort of notion
and i think hegel has in mind something
like that an orderly
structured everything has its place
everything can move the way it ought to
and this exists for hegel
in imagination not in reality we've seen
that played out
in all of this discussion in the
religion
as art
where religion was being brought to a
higher level the interconnection between
humans and gods but it all turned out to
be
in imagination or in representation
rather than
in
you know reality vehicle kites or
in the concept the begriff so this
cosmic consciousness
this is something people could feel
people could buy into and hegel's saying
yep we lost that uh it's not something
that is available to us unless we're
going to
regress why would we want to do so well
it is as he says perfectly happy within
itself this cosmic consciousness he's
not talking about like a universal
consciousness running through the entire
cosmos the great logos he's talking
about you and me
thinking cosmically that way oh about
the gods and their wonderful thing
people lose themselves in this
sort of mindset in all sorts of ways it
doesn't necessarily have to be about the
entire cosmos it could be being a foodie
and sticking your head in the sand and
ignoring all the problems within the
food chain and you know
issues about who actually has access and
who doesn't and all the class structure
stuff you know it could be
you know just reading comic book after
comic book and being so elated that your
favorite comic book producer has now
created an entire universe for you to
inhabit with your thoughts and dreams
and chitter chatter with other comic
book people and maybe do a little
cosplay and you know just be happy about
that sort of thing and you know why
would people want that i mean thinking
ahead because life in many ways is
contradictory and sucks and you know who
wants to face up to that
well if you want to dialectically
advance rather than regress
you do need to face up to that and real
religion i mean here's another thing to
think about what would hegel make uh and
you see this not just among evangelicals
where it's so so pronounced but also
among some catholics as well this kind
of never never land that they create
where everything's in its place except
for the baddies who are over there and
they know they're going to heaven and
they've got all these you know purity
rituals and silly metaphors and crap
like that that helps turn people off
because they're living in a fantasy land
right what happens when that fantasy
land that cosmic consciousness that's
perfectly happy gets upset they become
enraged and hate and you know they
become almost the opposite of
christians they become antichrist in in
many respects right totally out of
consonance with the literature that they
claim to uh be for so perfectly happy
within itself
in zeke full coleman right brought to
its it's you know fulfillment gluck
leaking and we might say why shouldn't
be p people be happy you know um why
shouldn't we find happiness well because
this is kind of a for hegel a
pathological sort of
fake happiness
and he tells us some interesting things
about this
he says into the latter and this is
something i had to puzzle about a bit
all divine being returns or
why would it be into the latter and it's
definitely the latter
you know let's
this last thing that we talked about the
cosmic consciousness
all divine being returns what divine
being is returning fake divine being
divine being that is only in imagination
or representation that isn't what it
what it purports to be
and then he says or it is the complete
alienation and oyster
you know placing outside of itself
of substance this mindset over here is
happy
but at the expense of not being engaged
with reality
what about the unhappy consciousness
well first of all before we go on he
tells us that the unhappy consciousness
is two things
in relation to this cosmic consciousness
it is the counterpart gegenzaite right
so there's an opposition gagan you know
against
uh two two sides being placed on other
sides but it's also the completion
fearful stendigan right being brought to
its fulfillment
if
this cosmic consciousness doesn't
[ __ ] itself and lie about how
everything is so great
and it actually works through its
dialectic as we've seen happen in the
previous section
about
the spiritual work of art happening in
epic and tragedy
and ultimately in comedy
so then what do we know about the
unhappy consciousness hegel tells us a
couple things the first thing that's
really interesting tragic fate of
certainty of self aiming to be absolute
why does certainty itself have to aim to
be absolute
because if it's not entirely absolute it
isn't truly certainty of self if there
are lingering doubts or stuff like that
now the trouble is once you open the
door to that and this is what happens
with the skeptical consciousness that we
saw just invoked in the last paragraph
it may be that you go you open up the
doors of skepticism because you're going
to find something skeptical actually
means seeker
but it might turn out as descartes
points out in the first and second
meditation holy crap it once i open the
door to this
i might not not get to the bottom of
anything maybe i've jumped into water
and my feet won't touch the bottom
maybe i should have left the
flooring there and not peeled it up and
jumped in you know we see a similar
worry in hume as well as well as other
skeptics too i mean there's a whole
dialectic of skepticism that we could
talk about but let's move on to the next
thing
this is where i think it's even more
interesting the unhappy consciousness
and the unhappy self-consciousness that
hegel is transforming it into
this is a really key characteristic of
it it is a consciousness but sign
of loss failures
of something being gone that was
hopefully there but maybe never was
really there
and what is the consciousness of loss
consciousness of loss
of what is now
missing or damaged or diminished
consciousness of the loss of all
essential being in this certainty of
itself essential being
vase and height not vason v is in height
essential being in the
in this certainty of itself
and then there's a loss even of this
knowledge about
itself
right so it's a double loss it's a loss
of essence and it's a loss of its own
relation to what it has lost
isn't that incredible a loss i'm going
to say that one more time it is a loss
of something and it's also a loss
of its own relation to
what it has lost it doesn't even know
what it's lost now and hegel figures
this in another way saying
that this is the loss of substance as
well as that of the self
now it's not going to be lost for good
but this is a crux moment
right and then he says
it is the grief
so this loss transforms into an affect
of grief schmitz
which is expressed
right ausk
and it's expresses itself in this hard
saying
god is dead
why would the unhappy consciousness
which has been seeking out the divine
in so many different forms
why would it have to say god is dead
and why is this a hard saying is this
just hard to hear
you know oh we don't want to hear that
god is dead that kind of sucks you know
that's no fun well hard saying is
actually something that comes from
biblical literature as a matter of fact
it's a way of describing many of the
things that you know jesus in the
gospels says to people that they're not
really that ready to hear and hegel is
invoking that that notion here
this is a
a hard saying it's not something to
immediately explain it's not something
to wrap our heads around and then
immediately respond to it's something to
mull over and to take into ourselves
and it's coming out as an expression of
the unhappy consciousness
we as the
people following along the dialectical
path should think a little while about
what this actually
would mean what does it
feel like
how does it impress itself upon us as we
linger on it
you